there had been a Saturday of Celebration
here the center of Monterey Park was
full of festivities on the eve of
Chinese Lunar New Year the carnival
ended with Carnage
it was after night fell inside a
ballroom dance venue that a gunman
opened fire he is still at Large
as a Manhunt began there were few Clues
to the gunman's Identity or his motive
we don't know if this is specifically a
hate crime defined by law
but who walks into a Dancehall and guns
down 20 people
the description we have now is of a male
Asian in this city east of Los Angeles
where the majority Asian American
population they spoke of the shock and
grief
um it's difficult to believe that it
happened here in Monterey Park we want
to express our condolences to the
victims and our families and moving
forward you know it is important that we
be there for them to provide services
and support they need and what will be a
time of healing in next week's months if
not years
10 people were found dead inside the
venue with the shooting two planes at
least 10 others have been taken to
hospital their conditions are described
as ranging from critical to stable
the figures mark this out as one of
California's worst ever mass shootings
while the gunman is still at large a
state in shock remains in a state of
fear